Okay, so I'd like to talk about this a
new concept called a Cache Stampede. So we, we've
got a use case now, you know a user
makes a request and a request probably bounces off our
cache and returns. Now if, if a user makes
the, a post request that edits the database. We
clear the cache and on the next request from
that user, we go back to the database and update
our cache and return to the user. The user submits,
we clear the cache, and on a following request we do
the whole chain agian. Now, a problem happens when we
have many users. Say that one of these guys posts to
the database. Which writes the database, which clears our cache,
and then the rest of these guys, you know, they're just
browsing the site. They all come to the site at the
same time. So we've got all these requests coming in to
ASCII Chan and our cache is empty. They're all coming at
the same time. We just cleared the cache, and what's going to happen
is they're all going to say okay, the cache is empty, therefore
we must all read from the database at the same time. Cause
they're all like okay, cache is empty, we need to update
the cache, and them bam bam bam bam bam, they all hit
the database, running the exact same query just, so they can store
in the cache. This is called a cache stampede, and what happens
is the database gets beat up, and. You know that
query that only takes a few milliseconds before, because it is
a small database could take a lot of time. Or never
return at all because of all of the queries are blocking
at each other. That is something that we saw happen
at reddit we kind of went through this whole process kind
of learning as we go. Cached stampedes are really painful, but
the solution is Fairly simply. So a Cache Stampede is when
multiple cache misses from so much traffic create too much
load on the database. Or not necessarily database, whatever slow computation
you've got going on that you don't want to do
very many of. You know that you constrained for resources to
compute. Let's have a quick quiz and see if we
can figure out the solution to this problem. Okay how can
we avoid a cache stampede? We replicate the database to
handle more reads. Only allow one web request at a time.
Only allow one database request at a time, or database query, at a
time. Or, don't clear the cache, but instead overwrite it with new data.